I've been really fortunate and blessed
by mentors and in my own case I've
received almost no bad career advice
almost everything that my mentors have
given me has been spectacular advice
Peter Drucker saying do you want to
build ideas or do you want to build an
organization and I said ideas and he
said so therefore you must not build an
organization it was a great advice when
I asked John Gardner the question of how
do you know when it's time to make a
change and he said as soon as you start
asking the question that was great
advice and he has his challenge to not
be interesting but to be interested
great advice
my my mentor Rochelle Myers who said
should wake up every day and ask
yourself the question if you got a phone
call that said you had a terminal
disease and you're not going to be able
to cure it and you also get a phone call
that says that you've inherited money
and are going to be independently
wealthy would you change the way you're
leading your life and if the answer is
basically no you've constructed a life
that's a good life and you should ask
that question every year every few
months how am i doing on that I was a
spectacular advice I got the advice from
my great mentor Bill Azir who said look
you know you can kind of go at the world
in two different ways you can go at the
world as thinking about it's a series of
transactions or you can go at the world
as thinking about relationships and if
you build relationships you are much
more likely to have a great life because
life is people it was spectacular advice
I've had nothing but great advice from
my mentors so if I flip around and I see
the kinds of ways in which people seem
to have gotten advice that wasn't so
helpful to them it might have been
advice to stay too long doing the wrong
thing to stay too long when they're not
growing Irv Groesbeck has this wonderful
line don't spend five years getting two
years experience right and another
wonderful piece of advice about what not
to do the question always comes up what
should I do what job should I take what
careers should I take what path should I
take what company should I join in I've
come to the conclusion that's the wrong
question the question is not what the
question is who will you allow to mentor
you
who can you work with who have set the
values and the ethics and the character
and the standards and the mentoring
ability that you will grow no matter
almost what the job is so the worst
advice is advice that tells you what to
do the worst advice is the advice that
tells you what to do the best advice is
that which gives you principles and that
which is a question and that which
emphasizes finding the right people to
spend your life and time